good morning as you can see there is a
lot to clean up here in downtown Hong
Kong which is littered with all of these
downed trees this is a part of the world
that is used to being battered by storms
but this one was stronger than most
fierce winds tore through the streets of
Hong Kong downing hundreds of trees and
causing extensive flooding scaffolding
surrounding a building under
construction was torn right off and
windows all around the city were blown
out of high-rises airports were closed
and macau's casino shuttered for the
first time ever our team was near the
water as the typhoon approached in the
Philippines typhoon man coud hit with
the strength of a category 5 hurricane
with winds near 180 miles per hour
torrential rains have caused landslides
and as many as 50 miners are feared dead
after the bunkhouse they were sheltering
in was buried in mud at one point this
typhoon was the strongest storm anywhere
on the planet so far this year it will
now ring itself out over Vietnam for CBS
this morning Ben Tracy Hong Kong